وقع عده من القوى المدنيه ومجلس للسياده
السودانيه اتفاقا سياسيا ايطاليا يؤسس
لمرحله الانتقاليه مدتها 24 شهرا
ونصل اتفاق على ان المرحله الانتقاليه
تبدا من تاريخ تعيين رئيس الوزراء وتنتهي
باجراء انتخابات شامله
وبالنسبه للسلطه الانتقاليه فانها تشمل
المجلس التشريعي والمستوى السيادي ومجلس
الوزراء وهي مدنيه بالكامل
على دمج قوات الدعم السريعه في القوات
المسلحه
وجرما الانقلابات العسكريه وكل تغيير
سياسيا خارج الاطر الدستوريه
هذا هو قد رفضت قيوان مدنيه سودانيه اخرى
لاتفاق واكدت انه ادى الى انشقاقات
الداخليه ولم يحضر بتوافق بقيه القوى
السياسيه
بدوره قال رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان ان الاتفاق يعني توافقنا
على قضايا وطنيه لابد من وضع حلول اللهب
بمشاركه واسعه من القوى السياسيه
ان الموافقه على هذا الاتفاق لا تعني
اتفاق مع طرف واحد او ما جهه محدده
وانما هو توافق
وتراضي على قضايا وطنيه يجب ان يتم وضع
الحلول لها بمشاركه واسعه من القوه
المدنيه
واصحاب المصلحه
بنيه الوصول لمخرجات تنهي حاله الصراع
والتشاكس القائم بين القوه المدنيه
والقوه العسكريه حتى نمهد الطريق نحو
التحول الديمقراطي الحقيقي
وقال نائب رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني
محمد حمدان احمدتي ان بناء دوله
الديمقراطيه يتطلب الاعتراف والاعتذار عن
اخطاء الدوله تجاه الشعب السوداني وتحقيقا
العداله الانتقاليه لرد المظالم وفقا
تعبيرها
الدوله تجاه المجتمعات عبر مختلف الحكم
التاريخيه
[تصفيق]
هذا الاوف ادي الفرص البناء الوطني وتحقيق
السلام والتنميه والوحده والاستفاده من
التنوع وهنا لابد من التاكيد على اهميه
اقرار عمليات العداله والعداله الانتقاليه
وقلا ممثل القوى المدنيه المشاركه في
التوقيع الواثقه لبرير قلنا الاتفاق يهدف
الى توحيد السودانيين تحت رايه مشروعيه
اقامه سلطه المدنيه بغيه استكمال الانتقال
الديمقراطيه وتحقيقه اهداف الثوره
ان هذا الاتفاق الايطالي عنوانه استعاده
الحكم المدني الديمقراطي واكمال مهام ثوره
ديسمبر المجيده وغايته توحيد بنات وابناء
شعبنا تحت ظل مشروع وطني غائم على الحريه
والسلام والعداله والمواطنه في اقامه سلطه
مدنيه ديمقراطيه
تستكمل مهام الانتقال ومقاصد الثوره
وقال والممثل الروماني في السودان
توقيع الاتفاق السياسيه الايطالي بين قوى
مدنيه ومجلس السياده جاء الثوره جهود
الاطراف السودانيه لايجاد حل للازمه
واعاده النظام الدستوريه وضع المجتمع
الدولي الى الاستمرار في دعم العمليه
السياسيه في السودان
ولكنه يوفر اساسا جيدا وجيدا جدا
والشجيه جميع الاطراف الاخرين على
الانضمام
الى العمليه سياسيه والمشاركه البناءه في
سائل التحقيق
كما عود نشكر المجتمع الدولي الادامه
المستمر